what's going on dr. Ian are we on there
is that to me luggage no this is some
cheapo I don't know what to Sol ok I
gotta go to Cleveland in like a couple
hours so you are you like a guy like a
guy a fancy guy with the thing you know
it's a waste to do biceps on doctor yeah
appreciate that dr. Ian yeah yeah with
your a roomful of dumpy individuals on
airplane like this Louie Vuitton and
Gucci luggage why first of all have you
seen handlers throw luggage around yeah
like they look I was in the window that
they watching him they just throw stuff
on that that conveyor belt number one
number two am i impressed because you
spent like $1,200 for a stupid piece of
luggage like 1,200 yeah you know people
want to be able to to display their
wealth through physical that is I think
that way as you're walking through the
airport everybody goes hey that guy's
doing pretty good financially I wanna if
I had wealth like that I want to hide
the wealth you do I use Michael Strahan
collection am i really my suitcase out
there is Michael Strahan collection I
think is that JCPenney just plugged it
oh this cheap piece of [ __ ] to me not
this but I got to roll the outside
that's his thing and you know your neck
Strahan I need some luggage look it up
well you know here's a fine thing so I
went into the house and I had another
piece of luggage I don't know what it
was right he's like that's not my
luggage I was like first why you know
you have like secondly it doesn't matter
what luggage and what you have my stuff
I said okay fine so you sent me okay
that's nice
y'all tryin to make a livin Mike's
trying to string together enough games
to make it go what show did he all he
left Kelly in a wad up what a great move
right young
gmae him and Steve Harvey like is there
any real estate left for anyone's to
show no but but GMA is now like this
show forever it was like nah GMA second
to the Today Show now it's like now
anymore
not anymore Today Show is Lauer right
yeah
what you know our they added Megan Kelly
and it's like no way as to not having it
yeah but she's not megyn kelly is not an
hour he gave heard that they gave her an
hour like they called Megan Kelly today
yeah so they gave her hour afterwards
those kind they trying to make it like
one big kind of they gave her nine
o'clock it's not work that's not what
you want 9:00 a.m. you go from being a
fox she was a star right crazy she made
a bad move they would have paid her more
money and she still died she was bored
yes they were they were I mean I mean
like they were gonna match the money
though whatever she got they were gonna
match her she was this huge star
I heard Fox offer her even more and she
took less to go to that she had a
problem with the guy I thought she
wasn't she probably cuz he he had
already left I mean listen almost
everyone seemed to have a problem with
him but but she had left already so you
know I don't think she'd left go to him
he was gone yeah man I don't know I bet
I thought there was some kind of trouble
there I thought I don't know yeah well
you know you know may his soul rest in
peace he was active he was frisky yeah
he died right after that right
it's like Paterno dies [ __ ] I just
watched that movie dies two months yeah
seventy days after this whole thing not
if it's karma right because he died
roger ailes must have died I think maybe
a year or a year and a half right after
he got out then Joe Paterno then I don't
know there's some of these guys think
it's a weird thing it's like when when
when couples are married for decades and
the wife dies or the husband dies and
right away the other one that's like
some of these guys are just living to
work yes and the minute the work is
stopped and it's clear you're not
working again man it's over that yeah
shut down Cosby will be maybe maybe six
months that's my opinion think so
yeah because because I think these guys
are very lucky they get to do all the
[ __ ] they do and they get sentences
sentenced to if he had sentenced to ten
years he's not making ten no no no but
you will probably have I don't think
it's federal prisoners I mean I think
it's federal
yeah eighty percent of it was a state
prosecutor I think I think okay so I
don't know what eighty right I think
eight percent yeah but state is well
state dependent I said I don't know if
that's considered a violent crime or not
how much time will ya
rapey sure I mean they were sleeping it
seems so peaceful yeah what his lawyers
say the jury your honor technically yeah
yeah but I think they says like three
counts and ten years max for each
account so we got to be 30 or they can
make them all concurrent I'm right I'm
not I'm not I don't know this kind of
stuff but I think he's got a he's got a
serve at least let's say at least six
years at least can you imagine that six
years now that's a long time he won't
make it just because I think he's gonna
be heartbroken I think he's just gonna
die it doesn't again you know what I
think actually I think actually the
option for this reason I think he wants
to do a big fu to people and so he wants
to serve his time get out and be able to
say fu I made it if he can't do in five
years or less or four years if they say
you'd give you nine or ten you'll be out
probably with good behavior in three to
four right and on stage the stress
factor in that five I think if the
whatever he guess doesn't matter I think
the lawyer tells him you can be out in
five or in 60 months or less he can
mentally it would be terrible but he can
go all right I'm out when I'm 85 and I
could live to be I mean George Burns was
99 I could like it live another [ __ ]
14 is 14 years you just said George
Burns yeah I missed that dude I love
that yeah they just miss a hundred yeah
just miss just misses phenomenal game
Wow
Henny Youngman let a lot of those guys
just Bob whole but I forget how they
they all got pretty Moses name red red
buttons yeah how old oh you look at red
buttons hey how did all those guys your
nutrition guy I always wonder how did
all these old guys that live forever you
know smoking cigars drinking every night
eating red meat all the time
you ready yeah unbelievable jeans that's
it that's it too much about it
they had great jeans anyone else doing
that they would have punched out way
early I mean think about it he smoked
his whole life right drank their whole
life they ate what do you think is that
cutoff that like if you make it past
this age you're gonna be fine 99 I think
like it's like like it's like 80 yeah
they say if you live the 60 you're
either going to 80 go way up now well
yeah cuz you're dead
[Laughter]
you're saying a hundred percent of the
people who made it to 80 also made it to
cancer and died when you're 17 the odds
of hitting 80 Travis what you say to me
this is we have to fix this - you tell
me someone died which burns died two
months after turning 102 months after
100 all he made 100 hundred you might
realize that yeah he didn't enjoy it no
he didn't pursue money that's a goal for
everybody making 100 that's that that's
kind of the watermark of healthy and not
healthy or like amazing life or not
amazing document a key money out it's
nothing to him nothing every day that
been on I'm a man of my word he saved
all that money on luggage he just pulled
out a massive wad of cash and peeled off
five $100 bills
and he'll be acting the building in 28
minutes mr. loaf yes hello Anthony
yes let's recap how we discuss this yeah
I remember very specifically how we set
this up okay so we can have some fun
with the listeners okay way we set this
up was right you were gonna go on the
clean 20 right okay and you were gonna
not cheap but do the clean 20 million
twice for 20 days yeah and we were going
to put it to the listeners to see and it
was five hundred dollars if you do with
good transformation on the clean twenty
and we're going to put it to the
listeners to see whether or not they
thought you deserved to clean the five
hundred dollars right so we said right
so I think we actually have the clip if
we want to review what I do there's to
make sure everybody's on the same page
and there's no chicane er II because I
don't stand for chicane that's a good
word everybody knows that yes all right
listen here's the deal this is why I
like this we're gonna do a before and
after with you all right
you follow the clean twenty we'll shoot
the pictures people online who filed the
show they will vote on your reveal and
if they vote that you have a nice before
and after we will gift you five hundred
dollars what is
in there it is okay there it is that was
that was the plan
now you've got did you take the you
didn't post any before you post but I
have it sir from April 17th okay yeah
let me see all right I look very fat
there it's nothing
this isn't the most flattering first of
all I don't know why you need to do it
in your underwear like you said the boy
in that photo what do you think to
figure out she gave you a gold chain
here's some track card know why the
girls love it but he's got some Muslim
beads so it kind of like balances things
honest Buddhist Buddhist Buddhist B yep
okay just hold the picture I might want
to see what he looks like they're
Buddhist beads you just like him yeah
he's pushing his stomach out a little
bit there he looks fatter but I guess of
course he's not stupid trying to get
that horse he is look like Liddell had a
little I mean believe it or not no okay
I was frumpy we said okay so here's the
deal so tweet the show right tweet tweet
me tweet the show my twitter is at dr.
Ian Smith dr ia and Smith tweet me did
you post no I didn't let's take a shot
you right now real fast now we can post
it okay or can people see you let's play
I got yeah yeah yeah certainly shot yeah
and you're gonna think you're gonna have
to send that photo detroy and then Troy
you'll have to take a shirtless photo of
him so you can get hosts the before and
after on our Twitter account right now
yeah and I hadn't disrobe and then what
we'll do is uh if you guys want to we'll
do like a let's do a listener challenge
I guess by the way show Troy the photo
so that he can try to mimic the photos
yeah right yeah good good I got some
while he's doing his own disrobing and
whatnot
some listeners are really pissed off
there's like you go on that show and you
give stuff away to the guys they don't
need this kind of money blah blah blah
blah you know that true yeah we like
funny
well the listener is upset because they
don't get a chance to jump in so let's
do a challenge with the listeners oh my
god how about that this guy like maybe
like a thousand bucks
oh okay why not honey so can I
participate yes this is only the
listeners right here so we'll do best
before and afters right on the clean
twenty will give a women's and men's
division oh my gosh right to be fair cuz
I got here to email the text messages
well men you lose weight fast or another
okay fine I agree with you so we'll do
men's and women's division will do first
and second place how about that okay
what a second place get what will give
like let's give let's do the numbers so
let's give second place like 200 200
let's give 300 for the winner 200 for
the second place five each there's a
thousand dollars okay just to spread a
little bit so now the way you have to do
is the picture should be taken they
should be holding a piece of paper with
today's date on it you're a news a
newspaper yeah a newspaper write today's
date on no no you won it in the photo
right nobody's saying a newspaper you
can't yeah that's fine so good get a
newspaper or something that you can't
change it has the date on it tweaked you
to it
post poster before pictures before and
then post your after picture yeah I like
that I'm gonna be holding out a
newspaper hundred they wouldn't because
they want to UM known okay your your
first picture you're gonna be fatter
they would not be saved if you hold the
newspaper they're gonna want to take the
picture immediately because in a thirty
day one yes unless you lost weight over
the last year and you're using a year
old shot and you're cheating on the
twenty that's why you can't you have to
use the newspaper or some way to verify
you doctor newspaper but if I read the
headline I agree about enters the war
[Laughter]
go ahead and post if you're gonna
participate poster before pictures at
the beginning holding a newspaper right
you have until what's today to loose a
today today is the tenth I'm all for
today's the 10th okay so you have
between now and next and the 17th to
post your before picture between now and
the 17th right post it by hit you send
it to me at dr. Ian Smith on to the
Twitter DRI a in Smith and then send it
to me on instagram follow me on
instagram at dr. Ian Smith spelled the
doctor out so send it to me and the show
okay everyone listen men's women's
division thousand books and there you go
there is Photoshop fodder for everybody
I thought our Twitter account this is
the after you get dumped oh if you give
this five hundred bucks you got make a
deal yeah you are not gonna buy anymore
jockey underwear
I mean you got that strahan underwear
okay so can people nipples have not
changed size the nipples are so nice and
small but it looks okay let me let me
look at the can you Troy can you put the
two photos on the desktop so we can look
back and forth Adam that would be great
because I need to see this torso I like
it Anthony I like looking at it [ __ ]
worked yeah but what I really did I'll
tell you you will be the judge tell me
you haven't you have a theory about him
pushing the gut out I think like yeah
that's a smart business I mean I was you
know I would have done the same survive
under on a table quite literally yeah
you know it's right there now Anthony if
you are to win this what do you think
you do with that five hundred dollars
well um it's interesting you ask because
the Red Sox have lost two games in a row
so I'm gonna put it all on the Red Sox
okay so the plan is if you get this
money today you're gonna get would you
laugh me lost it oh my god it would just
make my day I want
to get it just so then he loses it like
I don't want to cost him the money I
want him to lose himself the money that
would bring me more much more budget we
can't open the pictures no we've now got
two people working on trying to figure
out how to open JPEGs so there must be a
problem with the computer actually in
this in this case okay so Rob was able
to figure it out so I'm gonna I'm gonna
shift more towards operator ever on this
one okay I don't need Troy's defense so
exactly what do you think we're gonna be
fair here then yeah that's not why we're
why we're doing this all right what up
to us it's not up to us as I'm sure
they're gonna be very you know I do see
more definition in the after without a
doubt you know I see suit listeners I
see some definition in the pectoral
region which is Troy's this encouraging
t-to you to see these results definitely
changed his underwear I mean I I see it
you talked about and the same thing that
I've complained about the titty and
belly area it looks like there is some
improvement in the titty and belly area
now you got a I turned Troy laughs yeah
sorry okay I definitely feel of handles
are smaller almost gone everywhere
peccatis first of all this is a man
respect him can we call them pectorals
talking about mine my titties titties
Troy's a mantua t yes he has titties and
that bracelet so you vote guys I mean is
a guy gonna get the 500 or not but tell
us how you did on how was it it was
great I mean I loved all the food that
you had I love all the shakes that you
had in the morning that I would drink
all of them the fact that now I eat kale
makes my mother very happy do we have a
Twitter poll up yeah let's make it like
an official Twitter poll yeah there's
enough weight enough you know Anthony
get the $500 yes what the Twitter uh
damn it Sam show is the Twitter but the
the shakes to just go out and buy them
or no you can make them at home okay all
the recipes are in the book weird it's
weird you were able to lose all this
weight did you have to send him like
tons and tons of popcorn and free blood
no no we had no communication because I
didn't want to
I want to show people that any person
can do this on their own without me
helping them obviously if I help you is
going to be faster or better but but
honest I want him do on his own we
communicate it once online I was like
you know talk to him a little bit right
but that was it I didn't call him
nothing so yeah plus you're trying to
hang out in a 500 yes if you write a new
tweet Troy you could see there's a
little option right there next to the
yeah that's it and you can just ask the
question I've never done this oh yeah
yeah it's actually I love making poles
oh yeah and then we can change the pole
length too I don't want it to be up for
the whole day we don't need a whole day
no should [ __ ] low $500 that's it great
perfect Troy Freneau put from from from
at doctor yeah doctor please write with
some of the plugin cuz I want them to be
able to send me their stuff yep okay
yeah and then oh yeah let's plug Vinny's
club while we're at it when is the
stress factory this coming weekend is
giving Dario and change and then Andrew
Dice Clay
dice is coming to 17 through 19 you
gotta get some very quick of course it
is stress factory calm good good one
hour this pole is gonna be active okay
is that good that's that sound looks
great dude yeah okay there happen it's
up there and we're gonna find out
because that way if we do it within the
hour
then we can find out if Anthony gets his
money too yeah even though we don't have
an hour left we can still get a little
bit of a vibe yeah yeah because we get
where it's going I got to you honestly
I'm the Photoshop and learning Photoshop
sir are you there sending gifts of
people throwing up
[Laughter]
nothing kind a good question just came
up on Twitter is your underpants t
wearing now inside out it's possible
back up back down elicits fire zhenya I
don't care for doctor in really but I
but I hate so but I hate [ __ ] love Wow
lady I don't know I like I like em bleed
for you [ __ ] oh she hates [ __ ] low deal
she doesn't love Ian and that's that
happens no no she doesn't care for that
guy will excuse me for breathing in your
world but if you own the road geez what
was my mother thinking bringing me into
your world without your permission
freak okay that's going I know also
dirty ass belly button let me see his
belly button he's wearing his underpants
inside-out after the shower what is in
the belly button you telling me in the
before photo there's nothing in that
what the [ __ ] is in your belly but
alright maybe I missed the you know you
put tape over when you shower if you had
your breakfast already jeez it's gonna
ready to come up it's terrible by the
way there's nothing behind those eyes no
you're really not dear yeah ok ok any
more comments yeah I'm sure they're
gonna be great you like the comments I
do they might be great yeah well it'll
turn around she's always been good to me
she'd me too yeah
trying to might show me the money I see
you not saying fan [ __ ] cannonballs is
chiming in this is good well hopefully
we'll have some matter how does he is
that him feel you have to do
yeah he's setting before-and-after shots
I eat you don't just know I get it
fair [ __ ] you can't just have the money
for losing weight 20 you know pick up
the clean connection that he gained
weight I think you uh what the beards
longer in the second photo so I want you
I mean in the first in the in the in
shape photos that's why I took to mean
he let his beard grow long and lost a
whole bunch of weight I don't know I
like fat fan [ __ ] better I like him
better fat I like a better fat yeah uh
let's settle for grown [ __ ] ok looking
[ __ ]
right these guys are no great job [ __ ]
love that somebody said thanks Bend and
Ronnie thinks been running Taniya see
that's good stuff let's see I what's the
poll numbers are there any up yes oh
yeah I'll bet there will be people love
Twitter polls do they really love voting
in a Twitter poll you know how the poll
is trending right now it looks like
we're it's 61% yes 61 which is because a
lot of our audience hates shitload I'm
gonna try to I'm gonna tweet out the
link from my Twitter - yeah yeah tweet
out this link cuz you only you've only
got the out I mean wow that looks very
promising and [ __ ] love are you gonna
bring the boys out to lunch if you want
know what nobody brings me to lunch
that's a good point is a great point
they don't feel like I feel so bad for
voting No
how do I tweet this out but the poll on
high you just retweet the tweet that we
just posted on Jim and Sam show okay
that here we go out yeah what is it
I don't see the poll in this one no no
it's it's in here it's up it's it click
on the account it's a more recent tweet
yeah let's just say yeah we tweeted out
two tweets with the two photos in it and
then oh here we go in the poll yeah it
was after so if people find the poll
they can just click that tweet and go to
our our Twitter account now it's 60%
let's drop it dropped I voted yes for
you all right I thought you did it but I
think you're probably gonna be smacked
right away again create a third option
no I have a bachelor party next month so
or two months so I got a stay will you
stay why because we're going to New
Orleans and I want to [ __ ] dr. Ian you
may not know everything there is to know
about [ __ ] loaf but I [ __ ] [ __ ] he'll I
said that's what I do
yeah this is Nico and I jerk off I
respect that you're young guy yeah what
the hell for yes or no I don't care it
doesn't if you don't care no I decided
to vote no I'm gonna yes it's now at
6040 yo 6040 you feel that money
slipping right through your fingers oh
yeah well it's like every night wait
wait wait wait [ __ ] loaf would you like
to put some money on whether or not
you're gonna win the bet
oh yeah you gotta do that you got it you
got it throw at least a hundred right
I'll put a hundred
yeah you're gonna put a hundred okay I'm
gonna box all right you put in okay
we'll put the would throw ten what is it
he is betting $10 that he will win the
500 but that's not fair I have $10 on me
41 what's behind 41 hey what no what's
your Twitter uh tiny Anthony
one-one-nine he's just so small I'm so
tiny he's a little guy except in the
stomach yard it's just tiny little [ __ ]
now I am
yeah you are although Anthony did tell
me unless 21:59 oh boy it's why you're
dropping like a rock he said tell me in
confidence dr. Ian that he missed his
soft drinks missus oh I miss soda soda
but you know so do you drink soda so dr.
Ian for that I'll tell you that also I
don't give a [ __ ] if I enjoy it did I
mean this is your bet if that if he
loses the poll that goes right back in
your pocket I guess well no no
technically yes but no so what's gonna
happen is if he loses the poll right
we're gonna take this 500 right and put
it into the kitty for the winners for
the listener oh my god so the listeners
have even more motivation to get the
$500 57:43 oh my god and the audience
just found out that if Anthony loses its
510 to them yes to them but it only goes
going 10 minutes until the show ends
though we are gonna cut the poll off at
the end of the show you have to that's
very fair yeah we have some cut any
promos that we got me if we got any
production bits I see I see no okay some
people think you win he looks like a
woman whose transition it's not positive
first off you prick because now with a
naked malicious slice think I give a
[ __ ] what a [ __ ] loser
don't turn against slice that mother
[ __ ] that that's on there [ __ ] both of
them oh no I don't feel that way my life
operator error that's a guy Oh
operator error
[Laughter]
listen KGB thinks I should get the money
I'm a fan of slice and glitter Jews and
the naked militia no I look terrible
there oh gosh
really yeah why did you wear your
underwear in I don't know why how did my
nipples grow that's true let's go to the
poll I voted no but legit think he
deserves it you see because we're
getting dr. Ian fans they're just like
oh yeah cuz doctor you know is a side
thing cuz the diet obviously work is
based on the poll I know I'm giving
doctor eat a plug while telling him has
nothing to do with you that is a good
point to bring up either way shitload
did lose the way he worked for you the
question we're ending up to a vote
what's right and wrong is out the window
I want to try this down I don't need to
lose weight can you believe this I came
here with no frickin books I'll get you
one for sure I'll get you it's good it's
good stuff it's good it's easy and it's
like 10 pounds average weight loss is 10
pounds in 20 days yeah and we got a
Facebook group yeah join our Facebook
group it's called the clean twenty we
got 12,000 people on it Wow and it's
awesome people like it's so like I spent
way too much time in this group because
I'm like obsessed with it but like I
wake up and they're like man I dropped
43 points on my debt my blood glucose
diabetics one day is like I'm sleeping
through the night in Texas one guy's
like you know I dropped 15 pounds and
first cycle it's crazy it's crazy we do
after the first 20 days same diet oh
yeah you can you could well you can
either emerge out of it or you can do it
again because it's regular food it's
like chicken turkey seafood cheese bread
I always say Sam once you eat right it
you lost a lot of weight how old are you
with your wait a few years
yeah a few years well few years it's
more than a few years maybe it is yeah I
don't remember this picture of Jimmy
before jeez let's do it right you want
to see a picture of fetch in here yeah I
like that Jim
yeah fat Jim was a miserable Wow that's
me making a face there look at me on The
Tonight Show the third one out right
there yeah that's just you right that's
just me talking
that's okay so 2005 said last day
shooting for lucky Louie right there
look at the one all the way on the left
so me making it weird the last day of
Lucky Lilly you can see no not right in
there so you had it there you go
that was me just a pig and then me and
Patrice at that [ __ ] wood you were
there how much are you there look at the
tree size two and a quarter
no seven is that in your face first huh
yeah my stomach your belly in your belly
in chin I was two and a quarter at one
point oh yeah I'm 170 now to 140 yeah I
was wearing long sleeves and flannel
understand well I lost all the weight
then and that's right you did yeah I was
fast fat and uh you know I'm talking at
a bad moment I remember you
barrel-chested got a really bad mustache
I mean I had it all going there other
questions so like I'm always interested
in what people's moments are cuz like um
what cost at his moment was he was on
the roll and said he was on the plane
and they asked him he had asked for a
seat extender and the girl next to him
was like you got to stop looking out of
control so he lost 45 pounds so what was
your my moment I never wanted to be fat
and I always wanted to work out at the
gym and take care of myself but my
ex-wife never want me to the gym said
you're trying me girls are so yeah swear
to God so I was just you know I was in a
shitty situation and I just didn't work
out so I ate and that's it now if I eat
[ __ ] food like it might taste good is
enough oh my god an hour later I'm like
what did I do to myself I say hell we
should probably check the replies on the
on the tweet oh they're just some
interesting ones coming in that I think
like Jim you should be able to see the
their replies as well there's a Paul
rich Hoss jr. he has a clip piercing his
belly button keep scrolling down there's
because of photo one that was left like
no you scroll down just right under that
there should be what I just saw pop up
on my phone it was a reply maybe
open the human face yeah right let's
take a look at the poll numbers people
are very creative with their Photoshop
certainly are they like to make them
unflattering 600 votes in so far we got
about 5 less than 5 minutes left oh wow
you're in well we don't know I know dr.
Ian Smith $10 covering my back tonight
in New Brunswick by the way all the new
brunswick tonight that's gonna be a good
show there's new brunswick and there's
also a Bridgeport Connecticut and we
have red sport yes
who's in Bridgeport hey our club just
opened in Bridgeport
why were you you got bodyguards I'm from
Connecticut yeah are you I'm from
Danbury yeah oh so much annoyance I
passed one bridge for good a University
of Bridgeport play basketball
hey listen when Manute Bol was there
you're too young for that but I remember
Nepal never to be sure after 7:00 yes
absolutely he played there and I'm my
twin brother nice to drive down there
and play ball in the gym and universe'
bridge for yeah good stuff you know
where the Barnum museum is yeah that for
the new club is oh cool nice area yes
good stuff we should also mention Troy's
band is gonna be performing tomorrow
that's right they're gonna be in where
Troy tomorrow night Brooklyn Magnolia in
Cleveland Oh Cleveland Ohio and the next
Saturday at output in Brooklyn next time
yes I'm going to Cleveland tonight I am
one o'clock to Cleveland cool well come
up if you're out tomorrow I'm not - yeah
oh yes yeah black heavier are you doing
any shows out there yeah playing uh my
band Black Caviar explained by me ain't
gonna do any promotions just playing the
show okay I'll give you a plug tomorrow
morning glory awesome thank you very
much you know Rover know Rovers more
I'll give you a little plowing show he's
awesome he bought this huge bus so they
D has this like traveling show and like
they go city to city sometimes oh really
yes phenomenal he doesn't show from
Dubai he was in Chicago like three weeks
ago so I was like on the bus and
syndicated to a bunch of different
margin I'm not mark any can take the bus
to all the different markets awesome
that's awesome it's awesome so and I'll
give you a plug tomorrow Rover Holden um
yeah let's take that let's take a final
zone I know this will be final it looks
like we're sticking at 58 we're in fresh
it refresh refresh
[Music]
he wanted any gets his ten back he bet
nobody $10 so where can people last time
it was left last time by the way the
doctor Ian
presented $7,500 it wasn't left up to
the audience it was left up to me and I
decided if that person should not that's
why we cut you out listen yeah the
listeners you guys can do it we said
$1,000 yes 300 300 200 200 men women's
division sent us your before picture
between now and 17th right tweet me at
dr. Ian Smith DRI a & Smith and follow
me on instagram at dr. Ian Smith he got
a spell the doctor out follow me and
send stuff to the show and so you know
we'll keep track and we'll come back on
and do our best we'll give them let's
give them like 30 days I guess 30 days
but clean 20 is the twenty day program
but we're gonna give you guys some some
runway so let's get wiggle room yeah low
will go wrong give you 30 days